Pro Bowler all-pro safety Tyrann Mathieu
how are you sir great it's good in your
voice again my guy right oh right back
at you did you watch Game four
last night there in Houston I did not I
did not I'm so busy
Jaguars game and we got a big one this
week okay so you're locked in you're
locked in on the Jags you're not you're
not you're not focusing on what happened
with the Rockets or what's going on in
the world right now I did see my pals I
did Seaton Wallace guys guys got the
rockers last night right Dave I mean we
just talked about that how Anthony Davis
says he is the best player in the league
and I love that speaking into existence
stuff I really love it okay that's right
you are a New Orleans guy and you're
playing there in Houston right there in
the Gulf South it sure looks like this
defense is beginning to gel tire and
what about from your perspective here
yeah I think the chemistry is getting
better obviously you know we added some
new pieces this season and you know
we've had some guys come in you too
because of injuries so we're constantly
trying to you know create more chemistry
and continue to jail but I think these
last couple weeks we've been playing the
kind of defense that we all expect us to
play well what is the I guess the
difficulty in getting on the same page
when you're going to a new team and
joining a defense where the front and
back end need to play together what are
the issues with making sure that you get
straightened out tiring well like I said
you know none of us have you know really
we didn't play in a preseason so we
didn't really have any large game reps
so it took us a while to kind of you
know get adjusted and get comfortable
and like I said it's really all about
chemistry you know especially in the
back end and then up front as well you
know having at the past must work with
the past you know defense so like I said
the last couple weeks up there have been
a lot better so uh you know we're
wrapping up and we think we already need
to be tell us forward tell me something
about the Shaun Watson I don't I don't
know that you've been able to glean you
know you already know he's special but
you know he's never never gets rattled
you know he's really composed
you know he keeps his composure
throughout the entire game whether
things are going good going bad and I
think that says a lot about you know his
leadership because we know what kind of
player you know he is
yeah and it's amazing it seems that what
a partially collapsed lung is what he
was out there with last week I know you
don't talk about injuries but that's
that's now out there that sound unknown
fact about last week is out there I mean
that's one thing I've always admired
about the guy you know even going back
to his Clemson days you know plan
finishing the game with a torn ACL and
you know just all the injuries and stuff
that he's been able to overcome so he's
a tough kid you know I think he
represents everything you know you know
that we that we want to be you know
going forward which is a tough football
team it looked from my perspective
watching that Sunday night game in which
he just got smoked by that Dallas
defense that you guys were also throwing
out there to it where did that Sunday
night game ranked in terms of a physical
game that you've played in the NFL Tyron
well it was right up there you know kind
of reminds me you know every time you
know we went up there to Seattle you
know it was always a physical football
game and at the end of the day it always
came down to you know whatever defense
showed up you know they were going to
win that game so we just pride ourselves
on really been a physical defense or
tough defense and you know no matter the
situation or the circumstance you know
we have to play defense you know we have
to create turnover the make big plays
Tyrann Mathieu Texan safety here on the
Rich Eisen show what are you seeing on
film from Jacksonville so far what
things don't be another physical
football game you know I think those
guys are gonna try to come in and run
the football you know I think the last
two games we played those guys as a text
and they ran the ball seven times so
it's gonna be a physical game you gotta
bring our big-boy pads and as a
divisional game as well so those games
always mean a lot well I guess since
you're gonna be playing the same game as
Jalen Ramsey I'd like you to run through
list of quarterbacks and tell me which
ones you think suck deterrent okay stay
away from that okay what do you think of
Jalen's game well I think he's one of
the you know best quarterbacks in the
league
obviously you know he's a high
competitor you know he wants to
spotlight on him you know he wants to
make those big plays a tough play so you
know he'll have a good matchup this week
which with Hopkins and I'm sure that you
know those guys will put on a show for
us but you know he's a great guy a great
competitor talks a big game but he can
back it up yeah I was about to say what
do you and the rest of I guess members
of the NFL who play the position think
of Jalen's game talking throughout the
week well I think a lot of guys they
don't mind it you know especially if you
were able to go out there and back it up
and we all know the kind of competitor
he is and you know you know I talked
trash during the game too but I think he
does it a lot more but like I said he's
able to back it up you know he's one of
the best young quarterbacks in the
league and I think he knows that well I
mean what uh what does talking trash
give you as a player what is it I mean
I'm for me rich every time I've talked
trash I was just trying to get in my
opponent's head you know I want him to
stop thinking about the game and start
thinking about you know me um so that's
where the level and the angle that you
know I take but you know some guys go
over the top but like I said some guys
could back it up so they could do that
well I mean wives girlfriends and
mothers I've been told is the red line
you don't cross things off limits
keep-keep family out of it can you give
me an example then of what your your
trash talk sounds like time well for me
it's kind of like a man go tell your
coach to put somebody else in the game
because you can't get open on me you
know what I mean that's kind of that's
kind of my approach you know well that's
when I tries talk has anybody actually
then gone to tell their coach to be
followed your instructions tire Matthew
here on the Rich Eisen show what advice
would you give Oh Dell Beckham tiring to
just really man um to obviously to take
a step back you know realize the
opportunity he has in front of them and
then just really collect himself
gathering himself
you know and then just move forward you
know I think anytime I was in a
situation where people were judging me
or maybe I would do I was doing things
that weren't right um I think the
biggest thing I ever did was just
continue to move forward you know I
never dwelled on it never thought about
it too too hard I always took the
constructive criticism and then I try to
move forward so as long as he does that
I think he'll be fine
obviously you know he's one of the
greatest Y receivers in the game right
now and you know we all want to see him
have a long successful no healthy career
well as a fellow LSU guy as you are with
him part of that LSU Tiger family
they're Tyron I mean and also somebody
who spends time on sidelines and also as
you just said you know talking trash to
an opponent what what what is he doing
on the sidelines can you give us any
idea of what is happening when we see
him I'm not really sure which so you
know I really don't want to speak on it
I just know that you know football is an
emotional game and a lot of guys put a
lot into it and when he don't see that
carryover and two wins you know some
guys get frustrated but you know I would
tell him to just be conscious of him
being a leader on the team man
everybody's watching him so it's
important for him to carry himself the
right way because like I said he is the
leader for that team whether he wants to
be or he doesn't he's a leader so yes
always keep that in mind was he that way
on the sidelines in college no I mean he
was the emotional guy you know he wanted
to catch every ball you know you wanted
to make the big plays he wanted to win
but um like I said sometimes you know
you could get too emotional and it could
become a bad look so I think that just
might take on time Matthew here on the
Rich Eisen show all right now talk about
your LSU Tigers they seem to be in the
mix this year huh yeah we don't real
good so I know we got a big game coming
up in a couple weeks alabama was gonna
really kind of you know dictate our
season so I'm sure coach or get those
guys ready to roll but really proud of
those guys and how they've been playing
and so hopefully they can continue to
you know play the kind of football that
you know we are
like saying from you know the Bayou
Bengals tiring Matthew here on the show
and before I let you go what what is
going on with you off the field with
your with any charity work anything that
you're you're focusing on in Houston
anything in New Orleans that I can bring
to the people here to to be part of
I don't yeah well I I just recently last
month I opened my Tech Zone in Arizona
for kids in these valley so they could
just go in there work on homework apply
for jobs I have some extra curricular
things in there like a guitar you know a
studio so those guys can go in there and
kind of set up talk studio on things and
you know obviously play around the
microphone so and then I have my you
know annual turkey drive which is coming
up in November so I'm excited about that
and obviously my time at the foundation
will do something really big for
Christmas world will will surprise 15
families in Houston this year so hoping
I think I have a great holiday so those
are just couple of things that I have
lined up you know next couple months
rich I love it that's great when you say
tech zone you mean you mean a spot work
where kids can avail themselves of
computers tablets etc that they might
not be able to either in a classroom or
at home so what you're saying right yes
sir that's exactly what it is screen all
right so how do people get involved what
can they do is your website or something
like that
yeah they could go to town iron Matthew
foundation.com they can send me a
charitable donation or they could just
follow my page and see all the things
that we do throughout the year and you
know in the different communities in
Arizona New Orleans and obviously
Houston this year so they could just
follow along there follow me on Twitter
I usually posted a lot so they could
keep up with me okay so you're locked
into the meeting rooms you're locked
into the film rooms you're not gonna be
you know getting those seats next to
harden and and Chris Paul behind home
plate you're locked in I understand hey
send my best to everybody there in
Houston your coach as well please you
got it that's Tyrann Mathieu Texas
safety the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience